-The Democrats won back control
of the House of Representatives
tonight
for the first time
in eight years,
putting President Trump's
agenda...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it happened.
...putting President Trump's
agenda in serious danger.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, cable news
was unanimous --
it was a blue wave.
-When you look
at what's going on here tonight,
this is not a blue wave.
-So, we haven't seen
the blue wave.
-There is not
a blue wave forming.
-It's not a blue wave.
-This is not a blue wave.
-It is not a blue wave.
-So, cable news wasn't sure
if it was a blue wave,
but we here at "Late Night"
can confidently say
that it was at least
a blue ripple.
[ Laughter ]
-Blue ripple!
-But, hey.
If you've been
in the desert for two years,
a little splash of water
feels like a damn tsunami.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So, come on, Democrats,
give me some good news,
or I'm gonna have to drink
this entire bottle of whiskey.
-NBC News is predicting
the Democrats will control
the House of Representatives.
-Yeah, I did it, anyway!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because that's
the thing about alcohol --
it works for good or bad news.
That's right, the Democrats
are projected to take control
of the House for the first time
in eight years
even though they
lost seats in the Senate,
and that's because the House and
Senate maps were very different,
as CBS explained.
-It looks like we have races
on two planets.
We have Planet Senate
and we have Planet House.
-That's right, the Senate
is a different planet,
which explains why Ted Cruz
looks like he burst
out of someone's chest.
[ Laughter ]
Now, tonight was a crazy,
frenetic night,
with results
that were all over the map.
In fact, things were so crazy,
MSNBC's Steve Kornacki
was wearing three different
mic packs all at once.
I knew Steve Kornacki was busy,
but I didn't know
he was on three different
networks at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
So, the results
were all over the place.
Just to give you an idea of
how crazy things were tonight,
Beto O'Rourke
lost to Ted Cruz in Texas
while Republican Kris Kobach
lost to a Democrat in Kansas.
Democratic Senator
Heidi Heitkamp,
she lost in North Dakota,
while in Colorado,
we saw the nation's first openly
gay man to be elected governor.
[ Cheers and applause ]
In a huge victory, Kim Davis,
the Kentucky clerk
who infamously refused
to issue marriage licenses
to same-sex couples,
lost her re-election bid.
And fun fact -- her opponent
was a gay wedding cake.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Now, here's the thing --
Democrats winning back
control of the House
is a huge development
for a number of reasons.
It'll stop Republicans
from repealing Obamacare
and drastically cutting programs
like Social Security
and Medicare.
It will also allow Democrats to
protect the Russia investigation
and will put Democrats
in charge of House Committees,
which gives them
a huge new power.
-If Democrats do take the House,
President Trump will wake up
Wednesday morning
to a very different
political scenario.
Here on the Hill,
they are going to
investigate this President and
his administration thoroughly,
putting it under
an intense microscope,
likely investigating everything
from the President's tax returns
to conflict of interest
to those questions
about Russian collusion.
-Even when a party
has only one house of Congress,
that can still
have a really big impact,
because once they're controlling
that house of Congress,
they get to conduct oversight
of the administration.
They have subpoena power
to help them do that.
-That's right -- Democrats
now have subpoena power,
and if you don't believe me,
Trump was just photographed
trying to sneak 20 years
of tax returns
out of the White House.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, Trump is at an
OfficeMax in Washington, D.C. --
"Yes. Do you have a shredder?
No, I, uh --
I just want to borrow it.
I can't afford to buy it.
Did you see my tax returns?"
[ Laughter ]
Democrats were at least
vindicated tonight
in their predictions that
they would win back the House,
and the story
of how that happened
is very much about the
two parties' closing messages,
which could not have been
more different.
Democrats' closing message
was primarily about healthcare.
Trump, on the other hand,
tried scare people
with racist conspiracy theories
about the migrant caravan
headed toward
the southern border.
The GOP's closing message
was basically this.
-We are going to die!
[ Laughter ]
-Trump's advisers
pleaded with him
to talk about something else,
like the economy,
and Trump tried but admitted
he found the subject boring.
-And what job numbers
we had today.
Did you hear?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, we'll go into that.
They all say,
"Speak with the economy.
Speak about the economy."
Well, we have
the greatest economy
in the history of our country.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But sometimes
it's not as exciting
to talk about the economy,
right?
-"Did you hear?
Well, if not, too bad,
'cause I'm not gonna tell you."
[ Laughter ]
That's the President
saying the economy is boring.
Dude, the economy
is your number-one job.
It's like getting in an Uber
and hearing your drive say,
"Sometimes it's not exciting
to keep your eyes on the road."
[ Laughter ]
Although he's right.
Talking about the economy
isn't as exciting.
You know
who could've told you that?
Barack Obama.
This dude rescued us
from one of the worst
financial collapses in history,
and every time
he tried to talk about it,
it was such a snooze fest,
some heckler in the back
would scream, "This is boring!
Show us your birth certificate!"
[ Laughter ]
Instead of talking about
the economy,
Trump tried
a different tactic --
campaigning with Fox News hosts.
Ahead of his final election eve
rally in Missouri last night,
Trump's campaign announced
that Fox News host Sean Hannity
would be joining him onstage,
which is weird
since Fox continues to insist
that it's not an arm
of the Trump administration.
So Hannity
issued a correction, tweeting,
"To be clear,
I will not be onstage
campaigning with the President."
So, there you go, Hannity said
he would not be onstage,
campaigning with the President.
Got it.
-Sean Hannity, come on up.
Sean Hannity.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, stay, come on.
-By the way, all those people
in the back are fake news.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mr. President, I did
an opening monologue today,
and I had no idea you were
gonna invite me up here.
-Oh, no idea?
[ Laughter ]
You ran up on stage
like a contestant
on "The Price is Right."
[ Laughter ]
You had no idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No idea he would call you up.
[ Applause ]
You just flew all the way
to Missouri on a lark.
[ Laughter ]
Hannity's like a guy who gets
a call from his crush
and answers on the first ring.
"Hi! This is Sean.
No, I wasn't just sitting here."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Trump was so desperate,
he brought up a ton
of special guests,
from Sean Hannity
to Rush Limbaugh to Ivanka Trump
to Fox host Jeanine Pirro
to Kellyanne Conway
to Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
I mean, look at these creeps.
It's like
the Brotherhood of Mutants.
[ Laughter ]
All they're missing
is Magneto hovering over them.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Trump obviously loomed over
the midterms
and exit polls today.
56% said the country
was on the wrong track,
and 55% disapproved of Trump.
And when Trump tried to campaign
for other Republicans,
the crowds
made it all about him,
as you can tell
from the chants at his rally
in Missouri last night.
Although, if you listen,
I'm not sure the chants
made a whole lot of sense.
-President Trump got elected
because of the Missourians.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we're gonna re-elect him!
-Four more years!
-That's right.
Four more years!
-That's right, four more years.
They want him to get re-elected,
serve half of his second term,
and that's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump also tried to scare people
about Democrats'
healthcare plans
by telling them that
the Democrats' push
for universal healthcare
would destroy Medicare.
Now, healthcare was clearly
a huge issue for voters.
In exit polls, more than 4 in 10
said it was their top priority.
Trump tried to use that
against Democrats,
but he clearly got some of
his talking points mixed up.
Watch him mess up
and then try on recover
as if that's
what he meant to say.
-If Democrats gain power
on Tuesday,
one of their very first projects
will be a socialist takeover
of American healthcare.
You know what's happening.
And your taxes are gonna triple,
maybe quadruple.
You're not gonna be happy.
I know you well.
The Democrat plan
would obliterate Obamacare.
It will also --
Which is good,
but leave the bad parts behind.
It will destroy Medicare.
-[ Laughing ]
Nice save, dude.
Whoo!
He got so confused
by his own B.S.,
he accidentally told his own
supporters to vote Democrat.
[ Laughter ]
"The Democrats' plan is bad
because it would
obliterate Obamacare --
which is good!
We're against Obamacare,
which is bad!
So if you want to get rid
of Obamacare, vote...Democrat?
I..."
[ Laughter ]
So, in the home stretch
of the campaign,
Trump somehow managed to lie
even more than he usually does.
And yet it didn't seem
to bother his supporters.
They either believe
every word he says
or openly brag
that they don't care.
One voter at a Trump rally
in Florida over the weekend
told the "Huffington Post"
that she was not interested
in whether or how many times
Trump might lie that evening.
"I don't care if he sprouts
a third dick up there."
[ Laughter ]
Wait.
A third?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God. Trump's lying
has gotten so out of control,
he's been telling his supporters
he already has two penises,
and they believed him.
Look, Trump might be happy about
the results in the Senate,
but the results in the House
are huge.
Democrats will now be able
to check Trump's power
and investigate him.
They're gonna ask
for his tax returns right away.
And if they get them,
they're gonna be running
around D.C., saying...
-Did you hear?
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]